csgo has finally received a new update
and even though it's literally just four
lines it sparked a lot of conversation
dust 2 is out and Anubis is in the op
got its first NERF since like 2015. and
finally finally the m4a1s problem has
been dealt with
or has it
alright folks before we get into it I
wanted to let you all know that we
joined forces with Predator gaming to
bring you guys some holiday gift ideas
mom if you're watching this there's
still plenty of time
foreign
[Music]
okay so I have always cherished the idea
of a more Mobile gaming experience and I
think the Predator Triton 300SE might be
the perfect solution for me it's got a
beautiful 14 inch 1920x1200 OLED display
some incredible built-in speakers and a
1080p webcam to show off my lovely face
but most impressively it has an Intel 12
gen core i7 processor which is literally
leagues better than the one I have in my
PC right now so if you really love me
you'd head to bestbuy.com and order one
online for me just don't read the Box
don't even look at the Box this is my
gift not yours okay there's only one
other thing I want this year but it is
super specific so just please hear me
out I recently obtained a backyard but
the problem is it used to be a mushroom
farm so practically no grass can grow
that being said I would still like to
have some people over and not stand in a
muddy former mushroom infested yard for
that reason I want some turf as in fake
grass listen I don't own this place so
there's no shot I'm putting my time
money and effort into maintaining real
grass roller to the fake stuff should do
the job just fine well that's it for my
holiday gift guide this year and listen
if I don't get anything that's perfectly
fine too after all the real meaning of
the holiday season is spending time by
yourself enjoying fresh watermelon and
ice cold glasses of iced tea and you
know hot dogs fresh off the barbecue
stuff like that right okay so last
Friday valve released an update for CS
go and most people were expecting one
since they usually pop one out after a
major but as always Val found a way to
surprise us to start off Anubis has been
added to the active duty pool and dust 2
has been removed yes for the foreseeable
future dust 2 is gone and the other
piece of that is ancient gets to
stay so why did this actually happen and
why are people like myself a little
tilted well back before Operation Broken
Fang many people thought that Anubis was
going to be the next map added he was
already getting played in The Reserve
pool so people thought that it was
getting groomed for release however out
of nowhere we got ancient instead and
although some people somehow like it its
stats over the past year show that it's
the most CT sided map in the game
tapston
no longer does have to shoulder the
weight all alone bro land oh he's gonna
just mow them down keto and tap some
jumping hopping across the flames and
that brings us to why dust 2 was removed
back in September of last year Dusty was
given a small update in order to deal
with those pesky mid-off shots at the
start of every round the t's visibility
was obstructed but as a result of that
change a map that was historically
t-sided had become ct-sided as of the
Rio major there was only like a handful
of teams that actually had it as one of
their picks now many people pointed out
that there are maps that are more
unbalanced so why removed us too well my
guess is that since dust 2 is one of the
most popular FPS maps of all time Val
didn't like the idea that it was
slipping in favor so maybe they took it
out to give it some much needed TLC but
for some reason people started sounding
the alarm like the maps never been
absent before but it very much was taken
out back in 2017. I highly doubt that
dust 2 is going to go the same route as
Kabul or cash but to be fair if anyone
could pick this up it would be valve now
what about Anubis personally I think
it's pretty sick I think it's one of the
most beautiful maps in the game right
now and its verticality is very
interesting all the times I played it in
rank so far I've had a pretty good time
and other than Nico who apparently is
not happy with this update whatsoever it
seems like other pros and streamers are
starting to get the hang of the map
secrets
the next change in vowels update is
possibly the most curious one the Ops
magazine size was reduced from 10
bullets to 5. you see other than one
small fix the op hasn't been touched
since its notorious movement Nerf back
in 2015 but this change might actually
make some sense even though the op seems
like its purpose in CS go is nearly
perfect you can make the argument that
it's a little overpowered it may have a
high skill ceiling but it's dead easy to
use but what is only having five bullets
actually going to change well I think
it's going to cause operas to take more
passive positions since they'll be
reloading more often and more
importantly teas are gonna have to burn
less utility on top of that Dimitri
actually pointed out to me that this
might affect retakes pretty heavily you
see using an op and a retake is already
a bit of a gamble but now people might
be even less inclined to use one since
it might just have two bullets in it all
in all I don't think this is actually
too massive of a change listen
previously operas could Ace an entire
team and then still have enough bullets
to Ace a whole other team now they're
just gonna have to reload everyone once
in a while I will say the timing of this
Nerf and Kenny s coming back
it's a little up last but
certainly not least especially to that
one guy that's always in our comments
section the m4a1s has finally been
nerfed after being an absolute laser
beam for over a year and a half valve
has reduced the gun's range modifier
from 0.99 to 0.94 meaning the gun does
less damage at long ranges meaning once
again it will take 5 bullets to the body
to kill and those very long range one
shot to the Head one shot to the body
kills that we're so used to getting is
not possible anymore unless you use the
m4a4 now once again what does this mean
well on top of people crashing skin
sites trying to buy back their howls
this actually might change the way the
two m4s have been historically used the
a1s was always the long range topper and
the A4 was that up close sprayer with
more bullets but now since the A4 can
still get those two shot kills at range
people might start using it to hold long
angles every one of these changes is
pretty interesting on its own but if
you're a suit like me you may have
noticed a pattern it's no surprise that
for over a year now things have been
pretty CTC sided in CS go the a1s dust 2
and ancient are just three of the things
that have led to this unbalance and to
me this is just valve's way of finally
trying to balance things will it work
only time will tell and when it comes to
Pro play we're probably gonna have to
wait a bit longer since last fall finals
won't be using this current build either
so for now the duty of balance testing
the game it falls onto us I'll see you
all in Anubis
the person The Entity that I refer to in
our comment section that always
complains about the m4a1s he he
basically had an account that was just
named something like the m4a1s is a
problem and valve isn't going to fix it
because they don't care but now if it's
changed which I don't know if it will be
will he disappear so is his is he like
my job here is done or does he have to
wait